so Queen Latifah is getting a talk show
pretty much everyone has a talk show if
you don't have a talk show
okay so Queen listy was getting a talk
show and she has already announced that
she is not going to talk about her
personal life and her sexuality which is
kind of curious considering that's what
most talk-show hosts do this is very
similar to when Anderson Cooper got his
talk show was about a year and a half
ago and wasn't going to talk about his
personal life eventually came out now
first off I am NOT I know nothing
private I am not privy to any secret
lesbian information so I'm not
announcing here that Queen Latifah is a
lesbian but it seems to be standard
knowledge that Queen Athena is lesbian
which makes no difference to me I think
it would be great if she came out if she
doesn't come out that's fine too but the
idea that you're gonna be a public
figure at this point in 2013 with all
the way gay rights have moved forward in
gay marriage and all that it just it
almost seems like she doesn't deserve it
I don't want to be that judgmental and
as a gay person especially I want to
give her the benefit of the doubt here
but I see this as just a really terrible
sign of how to go about doing public
stuff how's that I also just think it's
highly problematic I think that part of
one of the main reasons that it's a tool
that we see in in terms of interview
style you know in daytime shows and talk
shows it's because it's a way of putting
your guests at ease so if you're I'm
sitting here and I'm talking about yeah
you know I've just had my baby and my
husband and I quarrel you're like okay
is that so you know you're here to
promote your your movie yeah it's about
you know how this romantic comedy and me
falling in love for the first time and
it's really super awkward yeah yeah yeah
you're right that would be awkward you
know everything is an awkward segue to
something else because you won't allow
that kind of a rapport that naturally
will flows in conversation yeah and I
also think because she started out in
entertainment it's a it's very different
when you start out as like an Oprah
Winfrey right who started out as a
reporter so on this side of things where
it's a little bit more detached yes but
you're starting out as an entertainer
and I think that's that's part of the
draw and the comfortability and is that
they should know you they should
you and feel like they can talk to you
and you can you know talk to them yeah
point of giving a person a talk show
like it's not like Queen Latifah sitting
there going well I mean I'm a singer so
I don't talk about my personal life I
sing I'm an actress I act I don't talk I
talk like it's the Queen Latifah show
what are you doing a show for it right
and to announce to go ahead and announce
before here's the topic I'm not gonna
talk about the one thing that actually
everyone wants right is the one thing
I'm knocking about but giving her a
little bit of leash here is it is it
unfair of us to ask this of gay people
and I'm really only playing devil's
advocate here because obviously I've put
myself out there in that regard so I
don't agree with it personally but is
there some unfair aspect that we demand
her to be or public people to be totally
open about who they are personally I
think that where we are it's 2013 and
we're living in a space and in a time
that is the most accepting and the most
embracing of homosexuals in media than
it's ever been and I think she's at a
particularly powerful position in terms
of her career it's not as though she's a
newbie who may be afraid that oh my god
I won't work after this if anyone finds
out or what your Queen Latifah I
couldn't take a job from you like only
things that would help other people and
people watching her being like oh she
was strong enough to do that I should do
that and why don't we learn from history
it drove Rosie insane literally insane
that she had to go on and pretend to be
in love with Tom Cruise and throw Koosh
balls at the audience and not be herself
on the Rosie show right and I talked
about this with Rosie I mean come after
she came out I mean look her career took
off again and she was back on the view
she had his show on Sirius for a while
and actually is a mother again like it's
saved her life people like when people
are being themselves yeah and you are
gonna you'll isolate some of the
audience and say it's a little more
polarizing so it might be a little
riskier yeah but people like it when
people are themselves
she's a cover girl as his Queen Latifah
right isn't actually Queen Latifah again
she is a lesbian so stupid but if she's
a lesbian isn't she the one that's
actually causing the polarization now
because nobody can't not only does
nobody care but I know this from talking
about this of all time I can't wait so
the day comes that I never have to talk
about another gay rights issue when
everything is completely equal and
everyone's out or not or or who they are
that's it
and we never have it it's exhausting for
me I'm sure as straight people it must
be exhausting for you guys Queen Latifah
coming out would be that classic case of
somebody coming out be like this is my
announcement and everybody going
we know yeah we knew like yeah obviously
right right you know it's not we still
think the same there's no nothing we
know Jesus and it's also problematic I
think from the perspective of you want
people to invite you to into their homes
every day you want people to turn to
tune in turn on that channel and make
sure to watch you at 3 o'clock on
whatever you know whatever her time
thing is I think it's a daytime show
yeah and I think part of that it's it's
some similar to the YouTube space of
they need to feel like they know you
yeah yeah and the fact that you went
ahead and announced preemptively I'm not
gonna allow you to get to know me right
you made a pre-emptive strike that's
right all right so final thought on this
because we all we all are in the world
of talking and entertaining and all that
kind of stuff how much of yourself do
you feel is legit to kind of hold back
for it for your audience and for your
your public I think rezoning part of
being a public figure and asking people
to treat you as such like I want you to
make it so that I can make a living just
being myself and I just get to be me and
you just watch me is you are completely
open about yourself and and I've brought
my wife unwillingly into the spotlight
but she's had secrets about her put on
the air the chin like and I've had every
piece of information possibly about me
that I can think of oh this is funny
this could entertain somebody throw it
out there yeah yeah I think it's it's
disrespectful to your audience to not
just completely if you're gonna be a
public figure beep public yeah and it's
so funny because that's to me the secret
of Howard Stern's success and most
successful people is just be honest
about who you are and that kind of thing
what about you because you play you play
a lot of characters also but there's
still truth in them there is still in
there is an essence of truth I mean my
channel is a lot more outrageous than
I'm being right now but that's an aspect
of my personality I do say crazy you
know just because it's it's you know
comic relief and I'm a silly person but
I can have an intellectual conversation
as well and there are aspects of my
channel that show that I do think just
playing a little bit of devil's advocate
that whether or not you're a public
figure you do want some amount of
personal space and that but as a public
figure that personal space is smaller
yeah you you are saying I'm not going to
expect the same level you know said I
not telephoto lenses through your blinds
into your bedroom but you know so
there's still a certain amount of okay I
know when I'm out and about people may
come up and say I want a picture or I
want it you know that's a part of that
part and parcel but there is still a
sense of if you want me to feel like I
can relate to you there has to be
communication happening there has to be
a sense of I can share that you know if
I can come on your show and talk about
these things that's because you make
that a safe space and part of that is
that you've made that topic or whatever
it is open and safe and I can just be
myself and share that with you and you
have to do the same so I think there is
a responsibility there all right well I
hope we made this open and safe and you
felt that you could beat you while you
were watching Shana Malcolm Sam Roberts
there Twitter's are down there you can
find them on YouTube and we'll put all
that stuff down there and there is a
subscribe button which they yell at me
every week you have to tell people to
subscribe you just have to click it once
and then that's it it's very very simple
thank you guys for watching and we'll do
it again